so basically right now I'm going to make
a video call do you like me now video
basically doing crazy stuff that I think
guys like in a girl like being dumb and
[ __ ] and a good time danyoung like me
now with all this makeup on huh you
don't like me now do you like me to my
[Music]
channel
Oh what's going on YouTube it's been a
while since I've done a video like this
but this has been ahh whoa you just this
is a video about a girl who was trying
to explain why she believes she doesn't
have a boyfriend and a little package
buys except without the package you
think guys don't want to be with you cuz
you ain't gotta set up a jungle
ambassador big drama here then you could
have mine because mine's even lower back
problems anyways I'm pretty sure that's
not the reason nobody wants to be with a
girl that looks like she's gonna snap
somebody stick off oh and I really don't
understand why everybody is such a hurry
to get in a relationship which is like
12 or something girl let me tell you
what half of you know you can get with
somebody they gonna break your heart
leave you alone out there to die you'll
get 50 pounds get blessed and nobody
and go eat something besides a tic-tac
in a breakfast for lunch looking like
pepper and you ain't got breasts because
your body's using that fat to keep you
alive [ __ ] let me tell you something
girl when your voice changes like that
there is something wrong with you either
half-demon or that's just nope That's
not me
could you imagine chilling with your
girlfriend that [ __ ] happens maybe you
like that oh you know I like it tell me
how much you like I like it a lot more
the story is young lady you too worried
about why you don't have a boyfriend
you're too young for it and I top that
you got self-esteem issues you let me
feel good about yourself be happy that
you're you you know after I just
verbally abuse you in all honesty guys
when the girl with a little bit of
competition oshi got to have a little
swag and I'm not saying she gotta wear a
shirt that says you know [ __ ] is gonna
be [ __ ] haters gonna hate it seems
that your steps on your looks and let me
be honest with you if you honestly think
that this world is just based on looks
um then I would be screwed so for all
those fellas up it that might happen to
see this girl in person walk up to her
tell her that she's beautiful because
she needs it because if you don't one
day she might show up in your bedroom
and chop your dick off
[Music]
what are they arguing about
I'm an admin for them who told you to
leave this morning huh I have to come
here to find you next to a Vietnamese
restaurant huh
I ain't talk to you right now I was up
on this stupid we're public we plugged
one while we fight about this you know
what [ __ ] come on here
ladies I'm out of here oh my god is she
wearing love baby come back baby come
back where you going now
now look look I'm just saying I didn't
mean it what baby come on
don't what